skinny back but when i get set
down oh so you go front you wipe this
way
i shut up
that's weird you don't even know what
direction is the correct thing right
what is the correct direction front to
back yeah yeah
all right don't get what are you angry
about i'm not angry because she's a
weird feel sassy
all of a sudden you don't get to ask us
about it i know you're right you're all
right
ask mom those kind of dirty questions
yeah
we're just talking about beautiful
things you know
yeah you know the one memory that i have
that i feel bad about
me about you and i what is that one time
you pick me up from camp mm-hmm yeah
you pushed me i pushed you yeah i picked
oh my god
now he's trying to hug him yeah he
pushed me he's pushing me away
wait so you drop them off no no what
happened was i so i went to a
a summer camp yeah where they picked us
up in a yellow boss took us into the
forest for a month and came back
essentially
yeah then i said hi yeah yeah so all the
kids are
like getting off of the bus and i was on
the bus i remember
thinking and people were kids were
hugging their parents
but some cool kids weren't
they were like hey mom right and getting
in the car and that's what i wanted to
do
but my mom wanted to do cry cry cry
mouth kisses and the whole thing
it's why i pushed her and when i did
that it broke i could see it breaking
her heart
you know what i said [ __ ] shut up
on my tongue yeah go ahead yeah because
mean i always when i go to his school
stevens
i always put on makeups so it looks
better you know oh you did that for us
yeah oh
because i don't want you to push me like
that i'm very i'm sorry
i'm sorry i uh oh i'm sorry i'll never i
never i feel bad about it that's why i
brought it up i feel bad
i'm sorry she didn't do that i'm never
gonna do that again never i'll never
push you
now he's trying to hug him yeah yeah
yeah
and then just you know you dealing with
just the whole i mean just the whole
life i know the whole thing the whole
thing is
um it's beautiful though isn't it
beautiful
what life
[Laughter]
but like when i look at you know like my
uh
shoots or not your past tests yes it
wasn't so bad
i thought i grew up very poor yeah but
when i look at
all over the world i wasn't that bad
you know yeah and i thought i'm very
because my friend
called me peanuts i'm so small and
my face well your friends called you
peanuts that was the nickname peanut
pizza
you're small small smallest in the class
not now i'm kind of you know you're
small no
not with korean religions no i'm not
[ __ ]
i'm i'm regular yeah